[Music]
when I first started in the wig business
the hair alone could be up to 175
dollars an ounce let's just think there
was more money in hair than heroin
my stock of hair right now is probably
worth over a million dollars my name is
Nicolas Piazza and I'm a wig maker hair
stylist wait designer I started doing
wigs almost from the beginning of my
career
there's my 50th year actually these are
some covers that I'd done for some
beauty magazine I used two pounds of
hair to create this style I worked for
the Kenneth's beauty salon which was at
that time world renowned at all the
celebrities all the movie stars
including people like Jack one Onassis
and Marilyn Monroe will clients death I
opened my own salon on the Upper East
Side I was there from 1985 until 2010
and I moved into the salon I'm in today
at Gloria WAN
so it takes about five or six weeks to
make a wig the job of crocheting the
hair is called ventilating that's the
ventilating needles come in different
sizes so if we're doing very fine work
they'll use of a needle that only takes
one or two hairs in each knot and if
we're using a heavy wig we might have a
needle that takes up to 10 years in each
knot sometimes the more delicate wigs
actually take longer than the very thick
ones at one time there was the synthetic
wig boom and everybody had a synthetic
wig and now people seem to be much more
interested in the quality and they're
willing to spend the money for my custom
wigs range from 38 50 up to 5,000
dollars you know and I've made wigs
that I've had to charge more than that
for because I had to do them in a hurry
and pay through the nose to get it done
my clients are a variety of people it's
the kind of thing where you get a lot of
satisfaction when you have clients that
are undergoing medical treatments
sometimes it actually held them back
from getting their medical treatments if
they told that they were going to have
hair loss and then once they got the wig
and they saw that they look as good or
in many cases even better than they look
before they go into their treatments
with a lot better attitude
I don't know what sets me apart I care
about what I do and also I know I'm good
at it and when you good at something you
enjoy doing it the parties especially
the potential opportunities are a
beginning list though Evonik presque
tasks help review material
[Music]
raquel chiel reveal a horrible mess -
BAM - we'll live in Wichita fire
kissable pets a doctor I don't prove you
possess the pain you see no - the partly
visible in the cat Missal pepsi release
the peer counselor talk about you talk
which is fairly second tone tips doesn't
represent all lobbies of reps are a
unique collaboration within your browser
casa
a partial part in omayyad camera that is
not permit a big puppy
Chicana what remove a part of the partly
if we position our God is a lot to show
users social academic and referral cases
erroneous only we need a material on
memmer's surface you nominee
these are losses on the puppy Masha
trying to deprive le metió Sundberg a
little box on appeal denied by lachemann
no assisted mayor Phil see mayor so I
can't party - vomit
the diploma she says my completely with
simplicity or [ __ ] spot versus will
appear magic carpets in else's Audrey
Mariah passion Parkway no pesky foster
Vito Mata Hari beaucoup
las colossal a million is a party and
people because young duelist I the
possibilities talking I thought he
thought a bassinet
Samuel name I know Chris Rock was
impossible to feel DJ notify icon bar P
estoy possible ii can never you
especially since unknown anonymous you
when I pass your name anonymous you
[Music]
great big story we here mama we made it
everybody all you say that is better my
mom's what could even do this they think
we got our grandma's cooking for us
no this is us we did that right yeah
young man trap is is take risks and
prosper and that's what we do into here
so that's what we eat is tribe kitchen
fixing shrimps in the bag that tribe
kitchen is this is a spot where you
prepare products to be distributed
underground we just use that mentality
with food where our full-blown catering
service you also can ordered for
delivery during the week my team
consists of myself and three other guys
are calling my brother's my boy AWOL
DJ care and bad news we're a small team
but we get the jobs on all the time you
know I mean we've always Crips and
bloods yeah I mean that kind of stuff of
course I'm getting arrested and every
other day for nothing is shooting at us
so now the only thing we worried about
is some fool burning up like all running
out that's it
I was talking to my mom you got to do
something I'm like okay well what can I
do
I've seen that caught our blue
commercial on TV I'm like Dan I look
kind of cool I could probably do
something with that I know but you can
make good money cooking I'm motivated
started culinary school and that's where
I began to practice my craft you know he
really came in here I'm Vegas tealight
broke what we gonna do like we need some
money I said wait if we can sell some
food through Instagram I was like
posting my food and people was like oh
that looks so good that looks great and
I like okay now it's time for me to
offer this food to the streets like
howdy boy pushes though you know I'm
saying and it worked the key to our
success we never gave up man every day
that's all I think about is how can we
improve our company how can we improve
our food how can we improve the taste
even though I'm really in the house
trapping I feel like it's a real
restaurant I have one job making the
best clothing in the world
[Music]
my name is Martin Greenfield it used to
be maximilien groom felt when I was born
but we changed it to me that America
because I love this country
my craft is very difficult to define
because it's many things I am a maker of
clothing I know how to measure I know
how to fit people very few people could
match me I was responsible for all the
presidents Clinton I measured in the
White House Obama measured in the White
House so then I made them for fractures
we never had to fix nothing my life is a
sad life before I came to America
because I lost my family I was left
alone everybody was dead we were
occupied
ouch which was a month later I was in
the concentration camp a year and two
months it was my second day in Auschwitz
there's no more names because the
Thracian kept only numbers when they
called me they sent me to tell the head
they ever spoke my language he was
Jewish they asked me are you a tailor no
I said if you could show me how to make
the color
he says I'll make you a car showed me
have my god the pain is still in my
heart about my family I still dream
about my family like they're alive but
on the outside you will never know I
didn't think I was gonna survive I was
liberated by eyes now General Eisenhower
came in when I was fifteen and a half
years old when they worked in I shook
his hand crying
you saved my life I came to America
September 18 1947 they gave me the job
as a tailor I told my boss listen
Eisenhower liberated me I want you to
make him a three-piece suit like I wear
myself he liked it once he had the first
three-piece suit from then on you didn't
see Eisenhower and nothing but
three-piece suits so that's how it
started
I made sure we dressed all the
presidents with Obama first he wanted me
to copy a suit I don't copy anybody
everybody copies my suit so if he wants
me to make something I have to measure
next day sensor name it would be a
pleasure to meet you that I'm happy when
I'm at the factory my job is the most
important thing in my life quality is so
important to me because I know that's
what kept me in business and that's why
I'm here talking to you
[Music]
you
[Music]